hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a fun puzzle i received by email
the number
abcdef is a special six digit number
imagine placing it as the first row of a
6x6 table
we find the rest of the rows by
multiplying the number by 2 3 4 5 and 6.
this number has a special property
in every row there are six different
digits with no repeats and in every
column there are six different digits
with no repeats in other words this is a
latin square
and i should mention you're multiplying
the entire number in each row
for example if the six digit number is
one two three four five six then row two
would equal two four six nine one two
you're multiplying the entire number by
two three four five and six
not each individual digit in each column
so the puzzle is can you figure out a
value for abc def
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so i solved the seemingly impossible
problem nearly instantly because i knew
the fractions of 7 are cyclical
we start out with 1 over 7 which equals
14 28 and 57 repeating
you can remember this as 14 28 57
we can find the rest of the fractions by
7 as rotations of this number
for example to multiply this number by 2
we start out with 14 28 57 repeating and
then we shift the digits to the next
smallest number
so to multiply by two we find the second
smallest digit in the six numbers
this would be the number two
so we shift over the numbers so we start
out with the number two
so we multiply by two to get 28 57 and
14.
we can do this to find the rest of the
fractions to multiply by three we start
out with 14 28 57 we then look for the
third smallest digit which is the number
four
we start out with the number four and
shift over all of the other digits
we continue this process to figure out
all of the other fractions of seven
you'll notice these are all rotations of
the same six numbers
and we end up with all of the fractions
of seven
so how does this help us solve the
puzzle
well what we'll do is we'll go from
fractions to six digit numbers
so we'll just remove the fraction parts
and we now end up with the number 14 28
57 and all of these multiplications are
still valid
we'll now arrange these numbers into a
six by six table
and there you go
in every row there are six different
digits with no repeats and in every
column there are six different digits
with no repeats this is a latin square
abc def is equal to 14 28 57 and i'm
pretty sure this is the only solution to
this puzzle because this is the only six
digit cyclical number in decimals which
doesn't have a leading zero
but i leave it open to you if you can
find any other possibilities or prove
why this is the only possibility
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these math videos inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they've already gotten over a
hundred million views but the math
meaties never praise these videos and
they spread their negativity
let's be extra positive to cancel them
out
please help the cause by subscribing for
free to get the newest videos and
watching and sharing all of mind your
decisions videos
you can also email me a puzzle or math
topic presh mindyourdecisions.com
check out my books which are linked in
the video description and you can
support me on patreon to earn exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your positive support